FLOWING TO HER COUNTRY. HERE'S
MY LATEST INSTALLMENT IN THE
SERIES BADASS WOMEN OF
WASHINGTON, SEVEN YEAR OLD
CAROLINA AT THE UKRAINE HOUSE IN
D. C. SHE CAME TO THE U. S FOR
MEDICAL TREATMENT. THIS LITTLE
GIRL LOST BOTH HER LEGS LAST
FALL FROM A RUSSIAN ATTACK.
VISITS LIKE THESE ARE PART OF
THE JOB FOR UKRAINE'S AMBASSADOR
TO THE UNITED STATES. OKSANA
MARKOVA, YOU WERE RECENTLY ASKED
ABOUT YOUR JOB, AND YOU SAID, I
THOUGHT I WAS GOING BACK TO A
COMFORTABLE LIFE IN PRIVATE
BUSINESS WHEN THE PRESIDENT
ASKED ME TO SERVE AS AMBASSADOR
TO THE UNITED STATES. YES
COMFORTABLE IS NOT THE WORD TO
DESCRIBE, OF COURSE. AH! THIS
MARKOVA BECAME AMBASSADOR TWO
YEARS AGO THIS MONTH. SHE WASN'T
EVEN THERE A YEAR WHEN VLADIMIR
PUTIN INVADED UKRAINE ON
FEBRUARY 24TH 2022. WE WERE
PREPARING FOR IT. WE KNEW THAT
THEY INTEND TO ATTACK US WAS
THERE BUT YOU NEVER COMPLETELY
BELIEVE UNTIL UNFORTUNATELY,
SAMSON, HORRIFIC. LIKE WHAT
HAPPENS, I WOULD WAKE UP EVERY
MORNING AND THINK WAS THAT A BAD
DREAM? BUT WE WORKED LITERALLY
24 7. YOUR BACKGROUND IS IN
FINANCE. WHEN YOU CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES AS AMBASSADOR.
YOUR GOAL WAS ABOUT BUSINESS AND
ABOUT GETTING INVESTMENT IN
UKRAINE. I DEFINITELY DIDN'T
HAVE ALL THE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT ALL
THE MILITARY CAPABILITIES. NOW I
KNOW THEM BY NAMES, CODES, YOU
KNOW, AND EVERYTHING ELSE. BUT
YES, I BECAME A WARTIME
AMBASSADOR. NOT SOMETHING I WAS
PREPARING MYSELF FOR, BUT I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN EVER BE
REALLY PREPARED FOR IT. BUT I
THINK MY PREVIOUS FINANCE
EXPERIENCE EXPERIENCE. IS
ACTUALLY VERY USEFUL. HOW WOULD
HAVE HELPED THAT WE HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING FROM THE U. S.
PRESIDENT BIDEN CONGRESS ON A
STRONG BIPARTISAN BASIS IS ABOUT
SECURITY ASSISTANCE, BUT ALSO
BUDGET ASSISTANCE. ON MOST DAYS
SHE'S WORKING OUTSIDE THE
EMBASSY, SHUTTLING BETWEEN
VARIOUS GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AROUND WASHINGTON. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE AMBASSADOR TO
. TO BE THE VOICE OF UKRAINE
HERE. WE HAVE FORTUNATE TO HAVE
SUCH A STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE CHAMPIONS. I
WOULDN'T EVEN SAY CHAMPIONS OF
UKRAINE, CHAMPIONS OF DEMOCRACY!
ON THIS VOTE. THE YEAS ARE 3 68
. THE NAYS ARE 57 HELPING
UKRAINE HAD BEEN A RARE CORNER
OF BIPARTISANSHIP IN CONGRESS.
BUT NOW THE NEW HOUSE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IS DIVIDED ON IT, AS IS
THE GOP FIELD OF PRESIDENTIAL
HOPEFULS. THE FASTEST PATH TO
PEACE IS TO HELP UKRAINE WHEN
THE WAR I CARE MORE ABOUT
SECURING OUR OWN BORDER. IN THE
UNITED STATES THAN I DO ABOUT
THE RUSSIA UKRAINE BORDER. IS
THERE. CONCERN THAT THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THAT HAS BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY WILL WEAKEN AS
UKRAINE BECOMES A POLITICAL
ISSUE INTERNALLY HERE? I REALLY
HOPE IT WILL NOT WEAKEN. DO WE
HAVE TO INFORM AMERICAN PEOPLE?
MORE OF COURSE, IS ANY SUPPORT
THAT ANY COUNTRY AND UKRAINE
RIGHT NOW HAS IN THE US IS
PROMISED FOR THE YEARS TO COME.
DEFINITELY NOT. IT'S A TASK FOR
OURS TO KEEP INFORMING PEOPLE
TELLING PEOPLE SHARING THE TRUTH
WITH THEM. THE INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINAL COURT HAS ISSUED TWO
WARRANTS OF ARREST LAST MONTH,
THE SEC BROUGHT WAR CRIME
CHARGES AGAINST PUTIN, ACCUSING
HIM OF ILLEGAL REALLY DEPORTING
UKRAINIAN CHILDREN TO RUSSIA,
THE FIRST FORMAL CHARGES SINCE
HE INVADED UKRAINE. THEY HAVE
BEEN KIDNAPPED, DEPORTING THEM
TO RUSSIAN FEDERATION. AND
FORCEFULLY PUT ON THEM EITHER
THROUGH THIS HORRIFIC RE
EDUCATIONAL CAMPS, SCHOOLS OR
PUTTING THEM INTO STRANGERS,
FAMILIES. IT'S A CRIMINAL ACT,
WHICH IS SPANISH, A BLE BY THE
MOST HARSH SENTENCES. OLDER
AMBASSADORS, PREVIOUS
AMBASSADORS BEFORE ME, MAN, MAN,
MAN, MAN, MAN. YEAH SHE IS THE
FIRST FEMALE UKRAINIAN
AMBASSADOR TO THE U. S. SAID
THAT IN SOME WAYS WOMEN ARE
BETTER SUITED AS DIPLOMATS AND
ESPECIALLY AS AMBASSADORS. YES
BECAUSE I THINK WOMEN ARE, UH
PEACEMAKERS AND PEACEKEEPERS. I
THINK WOMEN ARE ALWAYS TRYING TO
FORGE PARTNERSHIPS, SHE SAYS HER
HUSBAND IS A HUGE SOURCE OF
SUPPORT. COULD YOU DO THIS JOB
WITHOUT A PARTNER? WHO WHO GETS
IT? IT WOULD BE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT. THE EXPECTATIONS
SOCIETY HAS FROM WOMEN ARE STILL
I THINK HIGHER, SO THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE STILL EXPECT THAT YOU
KNOW, IT'S WOMAN THAT HAS TO HAS
TO TAKE CARE OF CHILDREN. IT
DOES TAKE A CERTAIN KIND OF MAN.
TO BE COMFORTABLE WITH A WIFE,
WHO IS AS HIGH PROFILE AND AS
IMPORTANT AS YOU ARE. WELL,
STRONGMAN. MY HUSBAND IS
DEFINITELY ONE OF THEM. I DON'T
THINK INTIMIDATED. BY STRONG
WOMEN IN THE MOTHER OF FOUR, HAS
TWO SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN WHO
LIVE WITH HER AND WASHINGTON.
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS FIGHT
IS ABOUT. THEY HAD TO PROBABLY
GROW UP A LITTLE BIT FASTER
DURING THIS YEAR, AND MOST
UKRAINIAN CHILDREN DID. IT'S A
SOURCE OF INSPIRATION FOR ME. I
LEARNED A LOT FROM MY KIDS RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF GEORGETOWN.
UKRAINE'S EMBASSY SITS IN THE
HEART OF GEORGETOWN IN A
HISTORIC BUILDING THAT WAS ONCE
HOME TO REVOLUTIONARY WAR.
GENERAL FORREST PRESIDENT GEORGE
WASHINGTON VISIT IN THIS VERY
ROOM. THIS IS THE ROOM WHERE
WASHINGTON AND OTHERS DREW THE
OUTLINES OF WHAT BECAME DC
AMERICA'S CAPITAL. VERY PROUD.
ESPECIALLY NOW WHEN WE FIGHT FOR
OUR INDEPENDENCE. OWN